[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news live
from ukraine's capital kiev where
tonight large explosions sounded as
night fell on this city
a series of blasts hit major cities in
ukraine killing dozens as the russian
assault on this country intensifies
in kiev's main hospital
children's hospital sky news witnesses
children being treated for gunshot
wounds as doctors move cancer patients
to the basement
peace talks between ukraine and russia
held on the belarus border while a
war of words erupts between them at the
united nations
western sanctions begin to bite as the
uk government ratchets up their response
directing all ports to deny access to
russian vessels
half a million people flee the country
but the home secretary rules out
visa-free entry to the uk
citing security concerns
also ahead fifa suspends both the
russian national and club teams from all
international competitions
hello yeah we've come to um to join the
ukrainian
army or whatever of course
and british volunteers offer themselves
to ukraine's military to join the fight
here on the ground
[Music]
good evening from kiev tonight as
darkness fell here the skyline was
alight with explosions appearing to edge
closer to the center of this city air
raid sirens have once again been
sounding urging families to find shelter
underground once again it comes on a day
of attempted diplomacy peace talks were
held on the border of belarus and a rare
emergency session of the un general
assembly in new york meanwhile new
economic sanctions have also been
announced by the uk as moscow begins to
feel the impact of global pressure
to choose peace
ukraine is under attack from the north
the east and the south some of the most
intense fighting and bombardments have
been
around the capital kiev in chernov
birdianz kirsten and mario pole in the
second city kharkiv there have been
reports of dozens of people killed in
russian rocket attacks from the nearby
city of dunepro our correspondent john
sparks reports on the battle for ukraine
the russian government says it's willing
to negotiate
but the russian military has decided to
bomb
this is harkev ukraine's second largest
city as filmed through the windows of
its residents
it shakes and it shudders under a fiery
barrage
the attacks seem indiscriminate
the government says dozens of people
have been killed
in the north the city of chernhiv has
been targeted by artillery and by
missile strikes too
a popular shopping center was hit
and a residential building was partially
destroyed the ukrainian government said
there was an unknown number of
casualties
in the south the russians have taken
ground securing the city hall in
bergensk
but the community's residents did not
cower
instead they faced the enemy and told
them to go home
such confrontations have been replicated
around the country
[Music]
as the attack on ukraine intensifies the
parties met for talks on the border of
belarus
but there seems little prospect of
success
the russians began the day complaining
the ukrainians were late
we've been waiting all night to talk
while their civilians are dying said
their delegations head
the best russians here on the left said
little about their aims while the
ukrainians have demanded an immediate
ceasefire their president vladimir
zelinski seeks salvation in the west and
sees his country's future in the eu
we asked the european union to admit
ukraine immediately under a new special
procedure we are grateful to our
partners for fighting with us but our
goal is to be together with all
europeans
later he signed an application for
membership and posted it online
as the russians press forward the
ukrainians sign up here registering for
the army in the city of dunipro
we were asked not to show their faces
so many people have put themselves
forward the authorities are turning them
away
many are now making molotov cocktails
instead
their commander says he's inspired
the station in la viv in western ukraine
now stands as a beacon of sorts offering
passage to poland by train
and tens of thousands want a seat
so no late everything could come so
me and my kids and my mom we are going
to travel to poland first
i don't know which way now i'm gonna try
because it's really hard to do now
and then we're gonna go to germany
it is a difficult journey fueled by
anxiety and disbelief and their return
beset by uncertainty
[Music]
it takes courage to stay put in cities
like kiev as the russians deploy the
might of their military machine
they will not sleep in the ukrainian
capital but the majority seem prepared
to defend it
john sparks sky news in ukraine
well doctors have turned an area of this
city's main children's hospital into an
emergency department for victims of
putin's war
three children have so far been brought
to the facility with gunshot injuries
one of the patients a ten-year-old boy
died on route after his ambulance came
under fire from here in the capital our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes reports on the children of kiev
the trauma of war in a children's
hospital this boy was hit by gunfire as
russian forces advanced on ukraine's
capital
just 14 years old he suffered face back
and leg wounds three nights ago
his latest procedure described as minor
surgery
russia's invasion prompted medics to set
up this makeshift emergency department
three children have been brought in so
far including a ten-year-old who died on
route
that was the quiet place
with just kids with the scheduled
operations and now in one moment
it changes so okay this is war we are
two days ago we have the gunfights all
around the block with the artillery
fights etc etc
but this night was a little bit
cold so
and
the war changes the priority
so now if you can take a shower and take
a coffee it is luxury
he's barely slept
as well as preparing to treat war
casualties he and his colleagues have an
equally vital job to do
here in the emergency department the
doctors are tired
they're worried about an influx of more
patients and they're also worried about
what to do with the very sick children
who were being treated in this hospital
before the war started the rights are
off
because of their
we should be like nobody should see us
until we resolved life
four-year-old nikita has leukemia he
receives chemotherapy and blood
transfusions here but
usually
usually children should not even be in
the corridor the noise you can hear is
his teeth grinding
something he's done since russian
missiles started falling
this is where he should be treated but
his mother now has to shuttle up and
down from the basement where it's safer
for them to stay how are you feeling
dealing with all of this i'm sorry you
know
trembling hands are trembling um um legs
like you're you are in fitness gym
because downstairs um 10 000 meters a
day
steps a day
up and down with children with bags
she wants to take him out of the country
but it's hard our children can't live uh
without hospital without medical
treatment
you know it's just a few days and the
result so we should if we will go to
another country we should uh cross
their
border but with a doctor
they're not alone other poorly children
also stuck in limbo
fighting life-threatening diseases in
the middle of a war zone
debrahing sky news kiev
and we'll be talking to deborah in just
a moment but satellite imagery is being
keenly monitored in this conflict as
russian troops advance
through ukraine we can show you some of
the latest images
we've received today these maxar images
show russian ground forces in an area to
the north of uh here in kiev yesterday
the convoy was seen around 45 miles away
from the capital today rather closer 17
miles from the city centre it's also
grown in size from just over three miles
in length
to 17 miles long
today those pictures of the russian
ground force the russian convoy
heading slowly towards this capital city
and as i was saying deborah joins me now
i mean heartbreaking scenes in that
hospital but just more broadly we've
seen explosions on the outskirts here
today we've seen um intense fire fights
and shelling in kharkiv what is uh
happening what is more broadly the
situation here well i think for kiev it
was noticeable wasn't it those blasts
that we heard an hour or so ago which
one of our cameramen dean caught on
camera um
it it was the closest blast from where
we are in the center i mean the windows
rattled of the hotel
and it did feel um pretty ominous and
those images you're just talking about
the satellite images of this relentless
russian force growing and and coming
closer uh it's pretty sobering i think
what you can say
looking at how the war has played out
today the intensity of the fire power
that russia is now deploying um not just
here in kiev but also you mentioned
kharkiv and other cities have come under
significant
artillery rocket fire
in kharkiv there was extraordinary
images that we've seen
of the the damage that was inflicted
there and it really is a sign it seems
that russia perhaps thought it could
take it could achieve its objectives
here pretty quickly and swiftly with a
limited force
however it met significant resistance
that has surprised see maybe surprised
russia definitely surprised western
allies um and so therefore you're seeing
as western officials have predicted an
escalation in the lethal force used in
the dis indiscriminate nature of the
weapons that are being deployed too
which means of course as always in war
the civilians pay the highest price
civilians here in kiev
those who haven't chosen to leave living
now in underground stations car parks
basements
daring very infrequently daring to come
to the surface the streets uh almost
empty people only coming out to get
shopping it's an eerie sinister
situation and it's clearly something
that's going to get worse we have seen
russian military action inflicted on
other cities it has yet come to the
center of kiev and you can only imagine
that is what's going to come next and
the talks that have been going on up on
the border with belarus um
ukrainian
delegation meeting a russian delegation
i mean do we set any
you know store by that any chance of
that producing anything
yeah wars always end don't they
ultimately um through an agreement an
agreement to a ceasefire um so the fact
that the two sides have agreed to talk
is um is is something um but yes it has
achieved nothing russia uh while it
it clearly has the military advantage on
the ground here in ukraine in terms of
the firepower that it has it has also
been left reeling by the significant
western response to its its invasion
here i don't think anyone imagined
including on the west that the eu for
example the us the uk they would all
come together in such a way the fact
that eu airspace is now blocked to
russian planes the fact that russian
banks are no longer able to use
international payment systems the fact
that germany has reversed a policy uh
for years in terms of its defense
spending and also spending agreeing to
fund and deliver weapons to the
ukrainian armed forces that probably
will come too late um however
it's a huge uh it's a huge pushback by
the west and a signal of their absolute
abhorrence to what's going on here yeah
huge changes in foreign policy and i
guess the new on the nuclear thing we
should talk about yeah i mean that is
again it's again it's it's vladimir
putin he has had this unprecedented
response from the west to his actions
here
and rather than back down he's
escalating further it's escalate to
de-escalate as the theory but escalating
further by mentioning the mention of
nuclear weapons putting his nuclear
forces on high alert that is um it's a
very uh is a serious uh worrying step
and for the west having to deal with
that kind of policy move with nuclear
weapons the ultimate
the ultimate weapon it's it's incredibly
sobering yeah and it's still difficult
to believe it's all
going on deborah thank you very much
indeed well uh
crisis talks on the situation stepped up
today with an emergency session of the
un general assembly taking place in new
york the first of its kind in
40 years or so it's also been announced
tonight that the foreign secretary liz
truss
will travel to geneva tomorrow our
correspondent sally lockwood is uh
in washington alastair bunkel is in
geneva and sally will go to you first
and uh
well this uh is a rare meeting of the
emergency meeting and a powerful speech
from the ukrainian ambassador
yes that's right mark as you say just
the 11th uh unga u.n general assembly
emergency session of its kind since 1950
and we heard from the ukrainian
representative uh once again who spoke
very emotionally comparing russia's
actions by invading ukraine to world war
ii and calling vladimir putin's threat
of nuclear weapons what madness he said
now we also heard from the russian
representative who had a rather
different narrative as you would expect
and once again uh peddled uh this
message that they uh decided to take
this action uh by invading ukraine to
clear a genocide in the donbass region
something of course that very few people
at this stage
would believe
but of course
talks is what the u.s administration is
keen to focus on along with sanctions
joe biden spoke to
representatives from nato
members of the eu the uk and canada on
the phone in a call in the last few
hours about how to respond
to this invasion in ukraine and to
continue to coordinate its response now
we've since heard from uh the white
house press secretary jen sackey
who said that the u.s has decided it
sees no reason to change its nuclear
alert levels
at this time but we also need to be very
clear-eyed about his own use of threats
uh speaking about vladimir putin there
to msnbc now we've also heard from the
pentagon uh today now they've said that
they're still analyzing and reviewing
what putin's announcement meant
but they say they haven't actually seen
anything specific as a result of the
direction that he gave
at least not yet they said in terms of
putting their nuclear forces on high
alert
of course joe biden had two options when
vladimir putin made this announcement
to do the same and put u.s nuclear
forces on high alert or to choose to
ignore it and that is what we have seen
from the u.s president so far a very
calm response a sort of just strategic
silence if you like
over the weekend but certainly something
that they are continuing to monitor very
closely here on this side of the
atlantic u.s security officials knowing
only too well how quickly this could
escalate into a standoff between two
superpowers
sally thanks very much indeed alistair
bunkel is in geneva alastair liz truss
heading there tomorrow what do we expect
from these talks
you know not a lot i think to be to be
honest that might sound pessimistic liz
truss will have meetings with her danish
czech polish counterparts you know let's
not underestimate how important those
meetings can be you would speak to
deborah about
just how stagnantly effective the the eu
and america have collectively come
together in their response to russia and
a lot of that kind of hard work is done
behind the scenes at forums like this
but the reason for my pessimism is that
originally the expectation was that the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
would be here the u.n secretary general
would be here and the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov would be here
sergey lavrov has cancelled his trip
citing the fact that russian aircraft
are banned from european airspace now
anthony blinken won't attend in person
so i think any hopes that you might have
the u.s secretary of state meeting the
russian foreign minister behind closed
doors and perhaps trying to thrash it
out to get some sort of glimmer of a
breakthrough well that isn't going to
happen now let's trust yeah she will be
here and that is part of the diplomatic
push
but it doesn't have i don't think the
key players really that it needs to have
if we're going to find any kind of peace
or breakthrough emanating from here or
at least the start of it
okay alastair thank you very much indeed
now the russian central bank was forced
to sharply raise its key interest rate
to save the ruble from collapse after it
dropped 30 percent
against the u.s dollar diana magnay
joins us now
from
moscow and diana i mean how concerned is
vladimir putin
as he watches his uh economy virtually
collapse
well he
held an emergency economic meeting today
where he
um called what western sanctions and
what the west were doing he described
the west as the empire of lies um and
essentially
tried his best to look as though he will
manage to mitigate fend off these
sanctions but i'm really unsure as to
whether he will and the strange thing is
is that um i think i've talked to you
about this before uh that russia has
always built itself since 2014 as really
fairly sanction-proofed and it would
always point to this huge
640 billion dollars that it has in
foreign uh foreign reserves um and as it
turns out a lot of those foreign
reserves are held in g7 countries and
now the united states has said that they
will freeze the central bank's assets
held abroad um and that many other
countries will follow suit which means
that the central bank can't use any of
that foreign currency to prop up the
ruble which which is part of the reason
why we've seen this free fall in the
ruble it went down 32 percent at one
point climbed back up to about um climb
a loss of 15 percent um but i think this
is just the the the shape of things to
come
and once again this will impact um the
russian people and i went out today
and talked to people who were worried
about what was going to be happening to
their money and at this stage let me say
there are not huge queues at every cash
point um you know there are people
worried the banks are busier than normal
we have seen social media videos of of
long queues in certain places but it's
not universal because i think people are
only beginning to wake up and and hear
the news that the currency is going down
so it will take quite a long that time
for them to sort of recognize and feel
the economic impact but that economic
impact will be huge you'll see
prices in the shops rise especially of
imported goods
people who hold for example cards from
spare bank which is uh the the bank
which most russians bank with that is
now sanctioned that means that if they
go abroad the piece of plastic that they
have will be completely worthless their
their ruble will buy them very little if
they do go abroad so this is just the
beginning of a of a set of um
sanctions which i think will set
russia's russia and russian people back
very considerably for the next couple of
decades and when you talk to people who
are going out to the streets to protest
against this war they say you know this
is going to ruin the future that we have
this will isolate us completely this
will make us um into a sort of iran or a
north korea compared to the
opportunities that we did have and i see
no rowing back in terms of the sanctions
and in fact we've just heard uh from the
eu that some more names have been added
to the sanctions list dmitry peskov the
kremlin spokesman uh also some of the
big oligarchs mikhail friedman who heads
up alpha bank he in fact is was born in
ukraine and um
wrote recently uh that war was never the
right answer but that hasn't stopped him
being sanctioned um also alicia uzmanov
who we know from his role at arsenal um
and uh
and various others
so uh i think that the eu the us the
west have still further sanctions
measures up their sleeve and strangely
even though they said over and over
again if you invade
ukraine vladimir putin we will unleash
full sanctions hell on you i'm not sure
that he took it really that seriously
and it's only day five of this terrible
invasion and already the economic impact
is being felt back home
diana thank you very much and from
moscow let's go over to washington live
to the state department where there is a
briefing
going on let's listen in earlier this
year in the aftermath of
the summit meeting that president putin
had with president biden in
geneva it was in the aftermath of that
engagement that our two countries again
came out with a joint statement
reaffirming something we have said uh
since the cold war and that is that a
nuclear war cannot be won and must never
be fought that is something that the
russian federation has signed on to it
is something that we certainly believe
uh and it is a principle uh that we must
uh protect and preserve sure but that
was a while ago and then they invaded
and then they so then do you think that
they're still
within that understanding are the
indications that you're getting is
similar to what the swiss are getting
that they're not going to
follow through this tile well
clearly this is provocative rhetoric
we
share the opinion with our partners and
allies around the world
that this sort of provocative
rhetoric more than being unnecessary it
is it is dangerous it adds to
the risk of miscalculation it should be
avoided
we are
assessing president putin's directive at
this time as i think you have heard us
say we see no reason to change our own
alert levels
this gets back to
the broader point throughout this crisis
while russia was manufacturing it and
now that we are in the midst of this
unjustified premeditated unprovoked
invasion
we have seen the russian federation the
kremlin president putin himself
consistently uh try to turn the tables
by falsely alleging that it is russia
that is under threat that russia faced a
threat from ukraine that russia faced a
threat from a defensive alliance
that russia was the one
that had no choice
but to wage
a brutal premeditated unprovoked
unjustified
war against
its neighbor
neither we
nor nato nor ukraine
nor
any other country has any desire or
intention
for conflict with russia
at the same time we are unwavering in
our commitment
to extended deterrence and confident in
our ability to defend ourselves
and our allies as you've heard us say
our commitment to article 5 is just as
strong today as it was at nato's
founding more than 70 years ago
sir
thank you mark stone from sky news uh
thanks ned um first of all
can you give us any sense of what your
reading is of what president putin meant
yesterday is he talking about
uh battlefield nuclear weapons or was he
talking about something even more
frightening that's my first question
look i don't think it is why is it
responsible for me to try to interpret
to try to read into
what president putin might have been
signaling trying to signal
again we think that this type of
rhetoric
is provocative it is profoundly
unhelpful uh and it is at its core
dangerous uh we think it it should be
avoided
so to follow up
what is your assessment of his state of
mind and how are you accessing
uh that assessment i mean are
conversations like that with naftali
bennetts of israel yesterday and
emmanuel macron are they helpful uh
what's what are the lines of
communications to work out what's going
on in his head
well we are going to judge the russian
federation we are going to judge
president putin by his actions uh and
clearly his actions uh in recent days uh
have uh justified and given us cause
to justify precisely what we said we
would do uh in um uh in the in the
run-up to this unprovoked uh invasion of
ukraine uh president putin his cronies
the kremlin uh those around them they
are facing
the unprecedented set of economic and
financial measures
just as we promise not based on rhetoric
not based on
threats alone but based on
their actions when it comes to our
engagement um look here
clearly uh our relationship uh with
uh russia and the world's relationship
with russia
is different today than uh it was last
week or than it was
before this
unprovoked crisis began
late last year
but
we still believe in diplomacy we know
that diplomacy is the only responsible
sustainable
means by which to end this conflict it
is precisely why we are supporting our
ukrainian partners as they engage in
those talks other countries around the
world have continued to engage with the
russian federation if we need to engage
with the russian federation we have the
ability to do so ourselves whether it is
through the state department whether it
is through the defense department
whether it is through
any other channel we have with the
russian federation so those the
deconfliction lines are open in terms of
with defense or with state that they're
there we have maintained deconfliction
channels with the russian federation for
the better part of a decade now again we
think that
the ability to communicate clearly
is in some ways even more important
during times of crisis and conflict as
we are in now than it would otherwise
than it otherwise would be
yes
one more question to you on the nuclear
deterrent aspect of this um
what has happened to russia's nuclear
arsenal since putin said over the
weekend that they would be putting their
nuclear deterrent forces on alert
again we are not in a position to
characterize
anything the russians might have done
you'll have to ask them if president
putin's rhetoric was matched by any sort
of action we have had no change in our
posture uh at this time we don't judge
there is any need for a change okay and
then um after the talks today between
the ukrainians and the russians um they
announced that they'd have another round
in a few days
just do you have a response to that and
do you think
that the continuation of talks is any
reflection of how russia feels about its
military advances in ukraine
well as i said before we support ukraine
in its efforts to find a diplomatic
resolution to this conflict ukraine
sought before the onset of this invasion
invasion to do just that the united
states sought before the onset of this
invasion to do just that
our allies in europe sought before this
invasion to do just that the osce sought
to do just that the nato-russia council
sought to do just that at every turn the
russian federation
rejected
those offers of substantive constructive
engagement
now that the invasion we are in the
midst of an invasion we have heard this
very message from president zielinski
from foreign minister kuleiba
we
we you would be
right to color us skeptical
of what it is that moscow intends
what we've said before including last
week applies equally today
diplomacy at the barrel of a gun
diplomacy at the turret of a tank that
is not real diplomacy
we
are
ready
and willing just as our ukrainian
partners are just as our european allies
are to engage in real in substantive in
genuine diplomacy in order to see if we
can find a way out of what is a needless
brutal conflict but that diplomacy is
highly unlikely to bear fruit to prove
effective in the midst of not only um
confrontation but escalation
well before the invasion started we made
the point that we were all for diplomacy
uh but in order for it to bear fruit it
needed to take place in the context of
de-escalation that is in some ways even
more true
now um we are
supportive of the ukrainians engaging
with russian counterparts we are
offering um
as you know foreign minister coleba had
an opportunity yesterday to
convene with the g7 ministers president
biden has had an opportunity in recent
days to speak to
excuse me president zielinski has an
opportunity in recent days to speak to
president biden secretary blinken has
had several conversations with foreign
minister coleba uh on a bilateral basis
in any uh in any number of days so we
are comparing notes we are uh
uh closely
and we are supportive knowing what we
all
assume are the limitations on diplomacy
in the present context it is precisely
what uh
foreign and president zielinski have
spoken to we share a sense of skepticism
but at the same time we want to exhaust
every
potentially viable diplomatic avenue
yes
well there we are we're going to leave
the state department there most of the
questions are asked by sky smart stone
but uh
nothing really new just uh a restatement
of uh condemnation of what
vladimir putin is doing and also saying
that
diplomacy
was still possible
according to the americans there
now the sporting world has waged a
widespread boycott over the past week
implementing sanctions against
teams cancelling advertising campaigns
and cutting ties with sponsors and
tonight all russian teams have been
suspended from competing in global
and european football competitions by
fifa and uefa our sports correspondent
tom parmenter is at wembley stadium
stadium and tom this is a highly
significant move by the football
authorities
it is these are authorities who have
been very close to vladimir putin over
the years indeed russia hosted the last
world cup in 2018
but this decision i think was somewhat
inevitable given the backlash from so
many nations who were queuing up to say
that they simply would not play against
any russian sides that fifa who had
initially suggested that russian teams
may be able to continue playing under a
different name with no national flag
well that was just utterly unacceptable
to so many people within the sport of
football and that has prompted
the response tonight from uefa and fifa
in a joint statement they said
that fifa and uefa have today decided
together that all russian teams whether
national representative teams or club
teams should be suspended from
participation in both fifa and uefa
competitions until further notice
football is fully united here and in
full solidarity with all the people
affected in ukraine both presidents
that's uefa and fifa presidents hope
that the situation in ukraine will
improve significantly and rapidly so
that football can again be a vector for
unity and peace amongst people so that
means that russia will effectively not
take part in the playoffs for the men's
world cup which due to be happening
next month in march we also
have real serious doubts now as to
whether there'll be a russian team in
the women's euros competition hosted
here in england with the final here at
wembley so a major move from the
football authorities and also from the
olympic organizers today who have said
that russian and fellow russian athletes
should not be taking part in
international competition
okay tom thanks very much indeed let's
go over to new york now where the united
nations general assembly is holding this
emergency meeting and the russian
ambassador to the un is taking some
questions the regime against its own
people who protested and who were
opposed to what the maidan regime was
trying to implement
for eight years we've been
we've been trying unfortunately in vain
to
to make
ukrainian authorities to comply with the
minsk agreements and we went out of the
way to do so but from day one after 2015
in particular the ukrainian authorities
uh opted to uh to to sabotage first
and then simply to uh to deny and to to
cancel to abandon and to cancel their
commitments under the means agreements
before that they were trying to navigate
so to say within minsk agreements trying
to make them the way which suited them
but then it became obvious nothing works
and then in february in january in
february
2022 when
when
the west started to beef up ukrainian
ukrainian
state
with with
with
lethal
lethal
weapons
when ukrainian
authorities
amassed
120 000 servicemen at the border at the
border of the contact line with the bus
and when they uh upscaled
the
the
their provocations against those donbass
uh shelling and killing people again we
realized that uh that that leads us
nowhere uh and that's why uh that's why
president putin took the decision to
recognize the nets and lugansk republics
and to offer them within the treaty that
we concluded with their military
assistance
and that's why we started this military
operation in donbass in in ukraine uh
which as i said today in the general
assembly uh
was not the war started by us this is
the end of war that was started by
ukraine
uh
i think that uh i i i think that you all
know that
that
we we
many times we we said that we were not
planning uh military military operation
in
in in donbass unless unless ukrainian as
military ukrainian authorities in
ukraine military
would would
would directly threat those republics
which was the case and we have
credible information that the military
operation was planned and that was that
was a move that was inevitable in these
circumstances
thank you ambassador for the briefing
it's pamela from cbs news
there have been some reports
out of the border meeting on in belarus
from the between russia and ukraine
what is it in your view
that would
bring peace to ukraine and withdrawal of
russian
forces what is that and then a little
follow-up to valeria's question person
country after country
are coming to the general assembly
podium and and supporting ukraine
feeling that russia is the aggressor
what is your view of that if not
isolation thank you so much okay uh
what will bring peace to ukraine uh we
clearly we clearly
said
and that is demilitarization and
densification of ukraine
which
creates a clear and immediate danger to
us
also within the context of geopolitical
stability
because
as president putin said that if not
today or tomorrow
one day in 30 or 50 years
ukraine might and will perhaps become a
nato member uh that will move for
nato to the russian border and that will
be an uh an existential threat for us
and that is something that we will not
allow to happen uh what will bring to
what will
what will bring peace to ukraine and
pray ukraine announce it uh i answered
uh on the on the talks that were held on
the board of ukraine and belarus
were
were
finished at this stage
the result
you know the details of that are not
known to me but i know that there was
there was
a decision to continue those talks when
when and where i
do not know yet perhaps in the same
place
i i i don't know the the uh i don't know
the uh details as i said but i know that
today president putin spoke to president
macron and he uh he listed those
conditions that we we demand from
ukrainians uh and they are well known as
i said the militarization and
densification of ukraine uh commitment
uh uh to its neutral status not to join
nato and not to move the weapons to our
bodies i did not answer one question
that michelle uh
post to me which is about uh reports uh
about hundred civilians that there are a
lot of reports today and i said that
there are a lot of fake news there are a
lot of fake factories that produce those
news
we do not have we do not have credible
reports on on civilian casualties
of course warrior is a bad thing and
nothing anything can happen but uh to
call this to to consider those reports
credible
is is very difficult since we are we are
witnessing and we are encountering
a massive propaganda campaign
using using as i said troll fabrics
troll factories that produce those news
to which we referred to in our recent
statements on numerous occasions so you
just referred to this as war this is now
war
this is a special military operation
which which which is
which is commonly uh called
i i wouldn't call the war because uh
because war means in out
uh outright
military
hostilities but as you know we announced
it and we we maintain it that we are
only targeting military objects in
ukraine we do not target any civilian uh
civilian infrastructure nor the cities
as they report
thank you ambassador sherman bryce b
south african broadcasting can you talk
about your relationship with the
secretary general right we saw you in
the sec in the general assembly on
wednesday you had a very animated
discussion we couldn't read lips but we
certainly saw the body language there's
been a lot of criticism and and the un
argues that essentially all he's doing
is defending the uncharted that says
states must settle their disputes
through peaceful means which is not
happening here so that's one issue can
you what should the sg do in this
instance and in addition to that the
this notion of the denuzification of
ukraine ukraine has a jewish president
so it just beggars belief that you are
talking about nazis in removing nazi
nazis in ukraine when the president
himself is a jew
uh i uh
there was a criticism on my part on our
part of the secretary general for for
the position he took
on the crisis i do not recall as i said
to him directly and then out loud that
that he took similar positions in
similar cases and there were many in
fact
syria uh
take other examples there were many
where his position was much more subdued
but there was no body language rest
assured uh that was that was a criticism
within the diplomatic
diplomatic
protocol which i think i didn't overstep
uh on the only uh on the
on the fact that zielenski
has
jewish heritage
it doesn't matter because because
real power in ukraine real political
weight
belongs to to the radicals and near
nazis
who uh who defy the president who has
there have their own agenda
who who ruled the rule the ball in
ukraine in fact and president zelinski
who came uh with a landslide victory of
74 percent of the population
uh promising to end the war
first thing on the list of his
priorities but then he was slowly
backing off this
uh and he finished practically playing
into the castle into the hands of those
radical and neo-nazi organizations uh
which claim that they represent the
patriotic but patriotic uh
part of the ukrainian society
he
demonstrated that he's weak that he has
no political will and power in in the
circumstances he found himself in uh to
resist uh to resist those radicals who
who are the main
main political uh
driving force in in in current in the
today's eur ukraine
well there we are that's the russian
ambassador uh blaming ukraine for the
conflict he blamed ukrainian
provocations and mass killing in donbass
he said this is not a war started by us
russia it was started by ukraine
i mean whether he believes that or not
he said it and then he said war
is a bad thing and anything
can happen so the russian ambassador
there uh at the u.n justifying or trying
to justify what uh is happening here in
ukraine all joining me to discuss those
latest developments are two former
western uh diplomats the former
ambassador and uh uk national security
adviser lord derek kim darrick and
a former united states permanent
representative to nato kurt volcker
thank you very much for being with us
and uh um lord darek just first of all i
don't know whether you heard what the
russian ambassador was saying but
basically saying this is all ukraine's
doing
yeah it was a fantasy version version of
history or of current affairs if you
like mark and um
i don't think it carries any credibility
with anyone in the west
or you hope one would hope um
elsewhere
it's the sort of message which is being
pumped out to the russian people
i don't know whether they believe it
or whether they believe what
those who can pick up what what the west
is saying where they believe us
but it is one of the more classic cases
of
disinformation and uh and straight line
that you can imagine
and kurt volcker what do you think
vladimir putin's strategy is now that
things are starting to not go
so well for him in ukraine and the
sanctions are biting i mean does he have
a strategy anymore
well he's doubling down right now he's
moving in additional military forces
he's laying siege to civilian
populations attacking apartment
buildings and hitting civilians in
kharkiv in mariupol in kiev
he called the
ukrainian
[Music]
negotiating team to belarus today to see
whether he could get them to surrender
of course they refused
as you say it's not going well for him
on the ground but they are spending
yesterday and today trying to repair
some of their logistical supplies their
fuel supplies and they're going to be
hitting ukraine very hard again tonight
tomorrow tomorrow night and um
his strategy if you have one if you have
it is simply to try to prevail
militarily he's losing face and the only
way he doesn't lose face is if he
actually wins uh i think this is going
however to
turn out better for the ukrainians and
putin is going to look
very bad at this including russian eyes
um and lord derek the sanctions are
biting
the ruble is plummeting
does does vladimir putin care at all
about that
well it have been part of his plan mark
that
after 30 years of german germany's
allies trying to persuade germany to
spend two percent of gdp on defense they
just announced they will
that uh that the ruble is crashing that
they've had to put interest rates up to
20 percent um that russia's russian
banks are being excluded from the swift
system
um so the sanctions are certainly going
to have an impact on ordinary russians
and to the extent that there is already
there's some evidence of this disquiet
amongst the russian people
about what is happening
when they can't get money out of atms
and when they uh when it looks feels as
if there's a run on russian banks then
that will really hit home so sanctions
are certainly hurting
just one very quick point
our britain's usp is london as a
as one of the largest financial centers
in the world so it is crucial
that we carry through what the foreign
secretary and others have promised today
which is to
try and drain the swamp of russian money
in london and hit the russian bank
community as hard as is possible as well
as russian polyglots who've sorted away
money here
and kurt volcker i mean how do you think
vladimir putin will emerge from all this
will he be so badly damaged that is
his time could be up or is that
unthinkable given his sort of
all-powerful position
no i think it is quite thinkable
lord derek already mentioned the russian
public showing science disquiet i would
not at all be surprised to learn that
there is disquiet in the russian
military and russian intelligence
circles as well because putin is leading
his country to ruin
and that is certainly not something that
they want so
i think there are two possible scenarios
at this stage one of them is uh the
russian forces continue to get bogged
down they don't succeed the economic
sanctions bite it hurts russia
dramatically and people go move to
remove putin
the other is that he actually manages to
crush the ukrainian military so the
ukrainian public go into a resistance
mode
this will make russia a pariah globally
for years and years to come this will
also do great damage to russia but in
under that circumstance one can imagine
the potential for putin hanging on
and lord if that happens and the
government here is removed should the
the west and the british government us
government support
and finance a government in exile and
maybe even a military
in exile planning to take it
well
back
most worrying news in the sense today
is the fact that
despite heavy and extraordinary
courageous ukrainian resistance
the russian forces have got that bit
closer to kiev i think they're now is it
is it 30 miles away and they can bring
google wellness force to bear um
including overwhelming air power
so it may be as much as uh
as curtis just said that ultimately we
will be able to take care of although
advancing on the city is a different
thing from taking the city and it's
extraordinarily different difficult
you know to uh to actually take a large
urban urban area like kiev
if that does happen yes of course we
should we should offer sanctuary to the
ukrainian government i think uh i mean
kurt will know this but i think the
american government's very off of that i
think we would we would want to uh to
make the offer if it was necessary yes
and just finally kurt volcker i mean do
you see a kind of long
whatever happens here if he does take
over the government top of the
government you can't really tame a
people do you see a long
protracted messy
war of resistance
or quite determined the government has
handed out assault ruffle rifles to the
population
the and i've seen pictures of friends
former government ministers uh who have
their assault rifles and they are ready
to go fight
uh so i think this will be very
difficult for russia to hold even if
they're able to take
and so this will be uh a bloody awful
and protracted conflict for russia
uh which uh in the end i believe
ukrainians will win
and that's because um there is no taking
away from them their sense of identity
their sense of needing to live in a
democracy their sense of being european
so they will continue to resist in every
way possible and that is essential
that's why it's essential we do
everything we can to assist them right
now
before any government is defeated before
any military is defeated get them the
arms get them the
logistical support
consider a no-fly zone i know it's
controversial but it needs to be looked
at
but everything that can be done to help
them get through this if they make it
another week or so i think the time may
begin to turn against russia
okay uh kurt volker and lord dara thank
you both very much indeed
so what is the picture here it's been
another day of heavy fighting more um
intense bombardment of kharkiv uh the
second largest city also
explosions here in kiev on the fifth day
of the russian invasion this is uh sky
news coming up in the next hour we'll
have much more reaction to the russian
invasion of ukraine we'll be talking to
the envoy to the united nations as he
warns that his country may not survive
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's 8 o'clock this is sky news tonight
the top story large explosions close to
the ukrainian capital on day five of the
russian invasion
a barrage of blasts hit major cities in
ukraine killing dozens as the russian
assault on the country intensifies
[Music]
in kiev's main children's hospital sky
news witnesses children being treated
for gunshot wounds as doctors move
cancer patients to the basement
peace talks between ukraine and russia
held on the balleries border while a war
of words erupts between them at the
united nations
western sanctions begin to bite in
russia as the uk government ratchet up
their response directing all ports to
deny access to russian vessels
half a million people flee the country
but the home secretary rules out visa
free entry to the uk citing security
concerns
also ahead fifa suspends both the
russian national and club teams all
international competition
hello yeah we've come to um to join the
ukrainian
army or whatever they're called
and british volunteers offer themselves
to ukraine's military to join the fight
on the ground
[Music]
good evening tonight as darkness fell in
the ukrainian capital kiev the skyline
was a light with explosions appearing to
edge closer to the center of the city